[Music]
[Applause]
all right
somehow we stumbled on this movie in
bruges
i'm not big on her but uh let's see
roger ebert says the actors are
spectacular colin farrow following a
sharp turn in woody allen's dull-edged
cassandra's dream
gives a performance of ferocity and
feeling
oh that's peter travers at rolling stone
uh roger ebert four stars
ray finds is in it
brendan gleason a pleasure to watch his
face is a road map to all of his
character's soul
come on that's you're i'm not watching
him if you said that was hey read this
do you want to watch this movie his face
a road map to his character's soul i
could say the same about david pollock
espn college football analyst college
game day oh there's that face it's a
road map to your soul david
have you seen the movie in bruges
that is a hard no dan i apologize would
you watch it for us
and give us some more you got a lot of
down time you know when you travel
i know you're watching film david right
wink wink but
yeah yeah that's all we do right then we
just sit in the room and watch tape and
take notes yeah that's all we do so when
you call home and your wife's there with
the kids and you're they're having
spaghettios or something you're like oh
man i'm
i'm i'm chopping up this uh this pit
defense here honey i don't even have
time to go get something to eat i'm
eating out of a vending machine here all
right yeah favorite movie of all time
for david pollock is
oh
of all time i'll go rounders
i think fritzy that's high on fritzy's
list
now i do love rounders
but i hate rounders because
john malkovich
saying uh kgb
[Music]
[Laughter]
you do the accent better than john
malkovich does and he's a great actor
like oh my god
yeah that's that but that's definitely a
great i think i put shawl shake
redemption up there i put gladiator up
there i mean i
obviously those movies never never get
old but uh what about you what's yours
dan i don't have one
okay well give me a top five or like a
couple then
i don't have one i i i seriously don't i
if there's a born if there's a born
movie on i will watch that except for
when jeremy renner was born i won't
watch that but i don't care where it is
in the movie i'll watch a born movie
hoosiers hoosiers comes on i'm watching
do you have a problem with rudy like joe
montana does joe montana said
you know we kind of made fun of rudy
and it's you know that
he wasn't the story isn't told the way
it really happened
well joe's obviously got a better
perspective too being there at notre
dame and obviously you know being closer
to the program but i grew up watching
that movie and obviously the
the spirit behind it and the uh the just
the everybody being able to relate to a
guy giving their all and stuff so i
absolutely love the movie as a kid i
don't watch it as much now but like if
you're talking football movie you got to
go remember the titans or blindside like
i think those are the two for me that i
would watch if they're on all the time
but when you're watching like uh keanu
reeves is a quarterback in uh the
replacements are you grading him as a
former defensive player who wanted to
take keanu reeves head off
no uh
typically keanu reeves acting is it
really my forte anyways but um i think
he was he was okay as what was he falco
what was his name in that one yeah yeah
he was fine he was fine no i don't i
don't look at it it has to be the most
accurate thing in the world it's a
flipping movie for goodness sakes oh
okay
uh that's all i wanted to talk to you
about but i guess while i have you i
should talk to you about game day is in
columbus it's notre dame and the ohio
state coverage starts at 9 00 a.m
on the mothership and espnu how does
ohio state not win this game
um if their defense shows us that they
that they're what they are who they were
last year i mean if you watch the rose
bowl utah scored and did what they
wanted it will you watch michigan
michigan pounded them in the face and
ran the football and was more physical
than them or again early in the season
so you know ohio state brought in a new
defensive coordinator to solve their
problems does he solve their problems i
have no doubts about their offense this
dan this might be the greatest offense
in the history of college football it's
going to be on the list with joe burrow
and company with with lsu in 2019 they
just got so many playmakers and ways to
kill you but last year what cost them
being in the playoffs and a chance at an
addie was their defense and just
bringing in a new dc doesn't necessarily
fix that so to me that would be notre
dame's chances to play physical and what
that's what they like to do best anyways
do you think that joe burrow lsu tiger
offense best offense you've ever seen
that uh kyler murray in 2018 was was
pretty stupid shoot mac jones was pretty
impressive
um
yeah i i would go with that just because
i think that they they could run the
football they could throw but you think
about it now and we look back
revisionist history obviously justin
jefferson guy is pretty good in the nfl
he's he's okay jamar chase that guy he's
pretty good like you look back at a
one-two punch at wide receiver i mean my
goodness i don't know if it's going to
get you know much better than that so i
would go and then joe burrow obviously
just i mean that dude you saw what he
did in one year with the bangles he was
just so good at
physical tough but could run and
scramble and make plays did he have the
greatest season is that the greatest
season a college quarterback has ever
had
joe burrow yes and and the greatest
transformation i've ever seen from one
year to the next i mean this is a guy
that i'm like he's a decent player you
know a cute little story transferred
from ohio state going to lsu and then
all of a sudden he's just dropping dimes
everywhere all over the field taking
shots taking hits and takes an lsu
offense that we go
they suck
they're pro style they just run the
football they're boring they're
monotonous too hey let's spread it out
let's throw it all over the yard and by
the way i think the coolest thing dan
was he did it with swag always he always
had that
moxie and just like kind of that kind of
you know you know what attitude that he
would just kind of stick it to you
i would argue for
johnny manziel
because everybody recognized the sec is
the best conference
johnny manziel led the sec in rushing
and passing
so
i just i i think that with johnny
johnny was the most exciting or the most
exciting players ever to watch but you
also didn't know what you're going to
get from johnny like it was like forrest
gump but life's like a box of chocolates
bro
but he ran for 1400 yards and 20
touchdowns david
yeah he could win a heisman off of that
and then you throw in his passing
numbers
well i mean are we gonna okay if we're
gonna do that too but passing numbers
were okay but what about cam newton then
if you're gonna talk about running the
football and setting the world on fire
that dude was a one-man band jump on my
back i'll take you to a national
championship and that's all you're right
you're right more impressive okay but
but johnny led the sec in russia
he also led the sec and parties attended
that dude lived his best life
okay you went to georgia did you get
cheated at georgia
did you party in georgia
no there's plenty of i wasn't much of a
i was pretty boring then i just i
preferred video games and football but
um georgia doesn't lose many parties
either
wow and let's be honest when you're a
football player
more opportunities tend to present
themselves to you so absolutely yeah
i've been to athens before um now leave
it at that
uh
okay
how does georgia
lose this game against uh oregon
i think it would be bone mix being
really good scrambling around making
plays because if you sell bow nicks you
know it's been a it's been a carnival
ride let's to say the least it's been up
and down and it's been all over the
place with bone eggs but he can extend
plays
over this
and make magic happen so he would have
to do that listen i get it i went to
georgia i understand
georgia won a national championship
there's also 15 guys that got drafted
that are gone 15.
let's spin the wheel and plug in that
guy no i mean all-time great players
that they're losing so getting georgia
early is a good thing is a good recipe
how about dan laney he was just there
celebrating a national championship as a
defensive coordinator he knows monken
the offensive coordinator he knows kirby
all these guys in the building which you
know try to use as much information as
you can get but bow next would have to
play sensation uh david pollock predicts
ohio state clemson utah and alabama will
be in the uh final four uh before i let
you go
the targeting rule
it concerns me it concerns me now
because
who's defenseless is a quarterback
defenseless now
uh i i watching the game i felt bad for
these defensive backs
i i don't know they're turning their
head away so you're not coming close to
leading with your crown like where are
we going with targeting here david
it's thanks man it's it's it's it's a
rule that we complain about every single
year and then and by the way now also
you throw all that onto it now i got to
go get this guy who's super fast get him
on the ground
but
he ducks his head and he lowers himself
to get underneath me or away from me and
now i got to readjust on the fly when
i'm already trying to catch this sucker
that's way faster than me anyways it's
impossible to be a defensive player i
was hoping that we could finally you
know do the you know you get one freebie
you know one kind of not so bad
targeting you get to stay in the game if
it's malicious and you're dirty kick
them out so be it like take care of the
sport and stuff like that but man it's
hard enough to play defense now you add
in all these rules and forcible contact
to the head or neck leading with the
crown of the head like
it sucks to be an official but it sucks
to be a defensive player period with
with all these rules bigger arms you
chris fowler
i got i got cf oh you do yeah for sure
yeah i mean he might he might bench
press a lot he's you know dan he's he's
getting a little bit up there in age
so you know
you get a little bit older you start to
lose a little muscle mass but but he's
still
he's still doing a really good job but i
got i got cf right now okay
you
kirk kerb street
well are we talking about muscle or
circumference
did you just call herbie fat
no
that he's
he's
he's good he's in good shape he's you
know he's like
he's no he's seven year old man i mean
he he's got the shape of a cantaloupe i
think is what you're saying
i can't believe that you're calling out
you just called herbie fat
oh god i could i could see those
headlines by the way that getting sent
to herbie and really really loving that
but no i mean
hey now desmond's desmond's a war daddy
like but kirk is uh
kirk is more of an incline walker he's
more of a he's more of a walker
what what the hell is going on with
desmond's picks
i got nothing for you bro
i mean he's got he's got baylor
pitt
texas did he think this was basketball
he's got michigan
yeah i don't know man i think uh you
know listen you know you know you get
all of our picks dan and we put our
picks out there and they're kind of
boring and i think sometimes you want to
shake it up but um
you know he shook it up all right and
and he went with his picks i don't know
that
i don't know that he i don't know i'm
not buying he might fully believe all
those picks but you know what if any of
them come to fruition shoot it'll be a
heck of a call
have fun there
in columbus now do you call them the
ohio state buckeyes
absolutely not i know they're playing
the notre dame fighting irish though so
thank you david
all right dan appreciate it that's david
pollock
former cincinnati bengal first round
pick went to georgia